like it's just because when you're
ranked number one it's just it's it's
different when you're chant
absolutely you know you know mike
there's traffic yeah but you know he's
this guy's definitely just going to stay
hungry because he made
he could he learned from the first fight
with um the champ
yep right you learn from the the first
fight you you know
you are him you can be beat you know you
came in that reality
before you know you thought you couldn't
be beaten you got beat by this guy
so that makes you even a better fight
fighter it should make you a better
fighter
should make you rise to the occasion
because you should know there's guys out
there
hungry just like you now guys who were
afraid of you when you were contenders
but now you're champion they're not
afraid of you no more they want to eat
you alive
isn't that something yeah everybody's
afraid of you when you're the contender
but when you're the champion that's
what's changed
they have to eat because you have the
best yeah
when you you're the contender you got
the bag you get nothing for them
yeah but when you got the bag what the
rest of them
you look at who could potentially be
next obviously
the main narrative is jon jones which as
a fan
is the number one blockbuster fight the
ufc can make but the only hiccup with
that
is john wants to receive compensation to
fight a monster in you
well he should he should he should agree
i mean nothing wrong with that
everybody in this position would like to
have a compensation
i mean uh basically a guy like jones
he's been around for very long and been
doing
uh this sport and this company grows so
yeah
i think there's nothing wrong about that
but um
once again i don't know what the deal is
yeah i mean you know so
um i would like that fight to happen is
that the number one
if you if if they gave you a list and
it's
john definitely be there number one
really
it's gone right like uh john it's
john john john definitely but um
at this point um we don't know what's
going to happen so
what do you think my job john john jones
francis how you saying that i think it's
going to happen
and ludicrous if it doesn't happen right
because this this right now it all comes
down to money right now
you know how can they do this they both
under contract do we do it under ufc do
we do it under this
and pay you know what do you do how do
you do this stuff
really you just really just need to put
up the money to please jon jones and
to defend jon jones here you know he is
the pound-for-pound
best fighter on the planet he's
undefeated
if he takes it what do you say 20 25
that's still for a big fight like that
he could say hey maybe that's nothing
but you know fighters have to understand
they can in a corporation like legends
only league
our fighters are like our partners you
know
it's not like we own you and you got to
go by our rules there's no rules you
fight you get paid you get your back and
everything's over and we everybody get
our money we go to separate banks
yep you know no one's anybody's slaves
oh no in france how do you feel vegas
odds came out i'm sure you don't pay
attention this but they have john
or they have john as for the first time
his career as an underdog
they have you as the favorite which it
might create that's a little surprising
i think it'd be like maybe even money
or maybe maybe you but it's like i think
they have you as like a
that's that listen no why it's that way
because they want money
they want to know because the odds are
they're gonna they're gonna work on this
they're gonna make this a david goliath
thing
and for the first time you know
john you know everybody's gonna look at
there's a big guy picking on a little
guy
and john is gonna be favorites and stuff
you know people
the fans the people that just the people
the thinking the sympathetic people he's
fighting the big giant and so
we're gonna root for him you know
american story we beat the odds and he's
gonna have a lot of people
he's gonna have a lot of the betting
odds it's a different animal than stipe
right frank
francis like as far as john compared to
the outside of the bed
for sure people yeah the public you're
talking about the public public
doesn't make sense yeah that makes sense
yeah
that makes sense but when you look up
that when you look at that match up
francis i'll see a different fight than
stipe right
yeah john john jones has uh definitely
has more
uh tools in his pocket than stevie
but i'm not sure if he's tough or stupid
though that's a fair point
i think two one of the reasons the odds
are like that
is i went back and watched jon jones
last few fights his last three fights
yeah he gets hit he gets hit and i don't
know if he's just not gonna
the fights to watch but those are his
last three i can't go back
we look at him but um he's always
capable in a situation like this he's
capable to rise above the kingship
this is not the last three guys that's
what i think yeah correct that's what i
think i
i think i think he couldn't get up for
those fights those guys aren't big names
so he's kind of fighting to their level
still one but with a guy like you he
knows he has to watch his p's and q's
yeah he's not because you take one shot
from francis
the fight's over he knows that so he has
to put
more work into it right then he's going
to develop more
the game away because you know he's
going to he's going to grab him and
stretch his
spider he's just he's going to try and
take him down yeah
he's going to grab his hands him he's
just an interesting guy
um john jones and he's bait too he's
creative he's tall
have you met him in a person he's huge
we are mems the same size
that's what people don't realize they
think john's is smart john's huge no
it's just not small
and agile yeah his iq man you know this
like his fight iq is
nuts john's the he's not the most
athletic he's the smartest fighter
that's why john's so good and that's why
and i'm not um
saying i'm not saying it's good that way
he'd live his life he could live his
life the way he want
but um that's why sometimes he he slacks
off he's just too good